so welcome everybody it's nine o'clock
uh we'll start with the first
workshop of pi data festival um
yeah so welcome my first uh gonna do an
introduction about the beta successful
and then i will introduce
tommy yost and marlow um so yeah
per day festival i'm happy you're all
here uh was a
big change going from a conference to
online festival
and uh yeah i think we have a beautiful
program for next week
i want to thank the sponsors for making
this possible
and you see here the first day
today uh we started my balloon tommy and
jost
with the first workshop keep the data
flowing and after
that you can see tonight you can go to
the keynotes i think it's going to be
a good day so a lot of great
expectations
so tom maloneyos are from heineken um
they are going to introduce you to a
package called great expectations
which helps you with cleaning data
there's a saying in data science i don't
know if you know it but it says like
80 of the time we spent on cleaning data
and the other
20 of the time we spent on complaining
about messy data
so i hope at the end of the workshop
that we spend a little bit less time
complaining about messy data
um especially if you put your models to
production
you want to still know uh it's the data
is as you expect
um so i'm going to give the floor to
tommy yost i'm alone thank you
so uh thank you so outgore thanks you
thank you for the introduction
so uh as cord mentioned today uh we're
gonna discuss a lot about
uh yeah making sure that the data
that is coming of uh into your pipeline
is actually uh
data that you think you're it's coming
into your pipeline so we're gonna
talk about the package that kind of
tackles uh
or tries to help you solve this issue
it's called great expectations
this is a great uh topic for the monday
morning because
i'm sure that everybody wants to discuss
data
by five issues in the monday nothing
better than that right
is can everybody see the screen i hope
so
so as core already introduced us a
little bit so
just shortly uh about us we're two
data scientists and uh just as a data
engineer
we work at heineken my name is
tomislov and i'll be giving this
workshop together with
with madelon and with with yours
hi everyone
hi there so uh suggest uh
to get uh on so uh
as i mentioned uh we work uh for
heineken i
think most of you are familiar with uh
with
heineken so for those of you who are not
uh we uh we make and we we sell
beer uh we've been around for quite a
while so
since late uh since second half of the
19th century
which is uh quite a lot at the moment
although our panicking like our main
brand is
very familiar with this is not our only
product so
some of you might know that we do have
more companies
under heineken doing all kinds of stuff
so in total it's more than 80
companies and all these companies
uh have a quite high level of of
autonomy meaning that you know we
believe that
there are the local companies that are
present in different parts of the world
know their customers
uh best and this is the reason why we
give also a certain level of autonomy to
our company now
we work within heineken in center of
excellence for advanced analytics
we started working there this the center
of excellence started
operating in in 2017 and
up until now we've performed
over 40 40 experiments where we seek
opportunities to bring value using data
within
heineken and uh yeah now
the time is uh has arrived you know to
start bringing
value and to scale up those experiments
and the
proof of concepts that we developed
during this time globally
now you can imagine because of this
this all these companies that are under
heineken that we're trying to you know
help out with
uh with making them more efficient or
more data driven
you know we want them to use our models
and so on and so forth
there's a significant this autonomy uh
results
in uh yeah significant differences
in in the tooling also the data quality
that they have available
and yeah this makes it quite challenging
to actually
scale scale up now today
during this workshop we hope to you know
share our learnings
that we learned over this time and also
introduce you to
great expectations which is a tool which
can help which can help you
solve at least part of this which
which can help you solve some data void
related issues
uh by the end of this workshop we have
three things in mind the first thing
we hope to encourage you to test your
data
in addition to testing testing your code
the second thing we're hoping for is uh
that we yeah that we managed to teach
you how to use uh
this uh python package at least on a on
the basic level so that you can actually
apply it
in your work and we would really really
like to
that you get your hands dirty uh
practicing
together with us so we have two sessions
with uh which are hands-on so it would
be great if you would
uh also follow along tell me to
interrupt you for a moment a little bit
on the
practice people are allowed to ask
questions during the workshop
uh yes yes of course all right so a
little bit on the practice side
for those who are not familiar we have
two panels called the q a
and the chat you can find them at the
bottom um
use the q a for asking questions and use
the chat to just say
hi or say anything else the q a panel
allows us to
moderate the questions a little bit
easier so they can get lost in the chat
but uh thanks tommy continue
[Music]
yeah cool if you have any questions
uh please do post them in q a uh yoast
and uh
motherland will try to try to tackle
those
later on if necessary i will return to
these questions and also help you out
so just feel free to you know
ask so what we have on the plate today
um i'm gonna yeah i'm gonna
introduce you to the basics so i'm gonna
give an introduction and by the end of
the introduction i hope
that when somebody mentions name great
expectations you will not only think
about the
charles dickens novel but also on on the
python package that helps you validate
data
then we'll go to the hands-on with uh
madelon
uh where she will introduce you with a
simple workflow so how to use a great
expectations in
the most minimal way possible then we
will go a little bit
a step further with yoast and this will
show you how to not just
use great expectations to you know test
your data but also how to
make full reports out of this
yes using uh this framework
and if there are time allows at the end
you will also hopefully you all you will
you have access to the git repository
that we made
and uh there and you'll find a data set
that contains mistakes so we will
challenge you to find the mistakes
that we introduced in this data sets
and that's uh that's it well by by the
end of the day
we hope if there's one message to uh
to really you know to be consolidated in
your mind
is the one that the debugging pipelines
is
very hard data pipelines is very hard
and it's best to try to prevent it if
possible
so a little bit of motivation
so if you go into the into the
on the great expectations website um
so you will see this term called
pipeline depth now what is the pipeline
depth
is it's best to explain uh
using an example so approximately uh
one year ago i worked on uh
mvp for those who don't know mvp stands
for minimal viable product so it's just
like a concept
product where i had to predict
some i hope you can see my pointer
where i had to predict some kind of
sales
and the way that the data was ingested
it was uh in form of a csv file so each
week
i would receive another file which is
kind of represents you know
each of those files represents another
update for the data
now the pipeline was quite
straightforward it's just
schematically shown here so we got a
bunch of
files you perform some kind of a
concatenation so
combining this information
make transformation so feature
engineering
and such
get this uh put this into the model
validate the model and produce the
output
and present it to the end user in form
of a
dashboard or some of some reports not
really relevant
what it is and this worked quite well
for some time
until the point where it didn't work so
the model started producing some
really uh interesting output
and uh yeah the business then went
to me and asked okay what is uh what is
going on
what's wrong with this uh output this
this is not this
from our experience this cannot be even
close to reality and uh yeah
so the answer i had to give is i don't
know i have to look into it
so what to do what to do what to do
um okay i did uh some
testing of course uh for the code but uh
yeah you you still
you don't have a hundred percent
coverage especially in a minimum viable
product so
what i did i checked the code whether
it's made something some mistake
in a model maybe i didn't validate it
properly i couldn't find anything
so okay probably mistake wasn't there
maybe i made a mistake in the
transformations maybe i introduced a
feature leakage or something
that i missed i i really didn't know at
this point
uh maybe something went wrong in
concatenation
i don't know so i had to eliminate each
of those things at the
one at a time and you know you're never
sure whether you didn't miss something
so you also have to go back
this costs all this cost me quite some
time and also
quite some effort and it wasn't uh
really
it was quite stressful also because you
have to you know the
people are waiting for the model to you
know start uh working and uh
it turned out that this whole story
was uh just because there was an issue
with the data
with the data coming into the pipeline
so the issue was not in the code not in
the model it was
with the data
um the point of this story is
yeah even in a simple case scenario such
as
the one described the ball above there's
really a lot of stuff that can go wrong
and the question is not when things will
go
not if the things will go wrong the
question is when things will go wrong
sad fake sad uh fact of life is that
uh data pipelines are
in general especially talking about
minimal products and pocs but also in
some
production cases data pipelines so i'm
talking not about
code i'm talking about data pipelines
they're very often untested
uh they're not documented necessarily
and this also results in them being
unstable
so when something happens boom
and this is when you when you think
about it this is this is really uh not
good because this can cost a lot of time
a lot of stress
and if the business relies on the on the
output
this will be yeah not you will find
yourself a very unpleasant situation
so generally you know talking about code
we tend to test it before we put it into
production
but we don't do the same for for
for our data pipeline so we don't test
the data before we
ingest it into the pipeline and you can
imagine that
an above scenario if i had kind of a
check here before i started ingesting
the data into my pipeline
that would just check whether the data
looks okay and provide me with feedback
yes or no
i could have prevented all this
very complicated uh situation right
now this is something that
great expectations can really help us
with so what is what
are great expectations
this is basic great expectations is a
command line interface space tool
or a python package so depending how you
how you prefer uh to use it uh
its purpose is to to to help with
testing
and with documenting data pipelines uh
you can kind of think of uh great
expectations as a
framework that allows you to
vote on quote unit test your data
it's free as in beer
it's open source so you can check the
code you know you can quando report
check the code modify it if you if you
want
um and it's uh important to mention that
it's still working progress
so the development is still very dynamic
so if you
are using it to keep in mind which
version
are you are you using because
some some changes are expected in the
future
thinking about the package as a whole
and the concept that it represents you
can kind of
uh the highest level overview
you can possibly get is looking at it
having two two components
and these two components are
expectations
and validations now expectations
are kind of you know what you expect
from the data they're kind of like
unit tests for your data some sort of
assertions
about your data
now these expectations are basically
just
very often just the methods that
represent some kind of statements
about your data and they're quite
readable from
for for us for humans so they have a
form like this so
expect column to exist or expect
values in column x y z to be unique so
this is quite something that's quite
understandable
now once we have this expectation set up
we come to validations which is the
second key component
and those validations are evaluations
of the data that that we have
against those expectations that we have
defined
and now the outcome of this validation
will inform us then whether
the data actually matches what we
expect of the data
now talking about uh great expectations
uh and using it uh the basic workflow is
very simple and it's basically centered
around a batch of data so what is the
batch of data you have a
data source right it can be some kind of
sql
um database or it can be uh just the
files on your system
um that and this can get you know
updated
over time and this means that it arrives
in kind of form of
updates or you can call it kind of batch
so
patch is uh matches your data basically
now once you have a batch of your data
you kind of you know you will
say what you expect from
this batch of data so this might be
something like i will expect columns to
exist
i will be expecting that values that i
find in column
x to be between x y
or for instance you can expect that
this the column values are of a
particular type
now once you have a data source and
you have so you have batch of your data
sorry and you have
expectations associated with the badge
of your data you can validate those
expectations
and the result of this validation
then you can use you know to to say okay
i i cannot tolerate this mistake in my
uh
in my data or you know continue with
your pipeline if everything goes well
um this will go through and and the
hands-on part uh of the workshop with
madeleine in a few minutes
so you know if something is not clear at
this moment
don't worry it will get it will get
consolidated there because this is
something that's really good to see
in action now
this validation result that you will
receive from this process
is is nice but it's you know it's uh
it's a
you will see it's a json uh json it's a
json format
dictionary uh and what will happen
is yeah it's not very human readable
it's not something that you can you know
take and present to the
to the to the stakeholders or to the
data owners because
yeah it's very difficult to read
now great expectations also can you know
take this validation process
a step further and
uh also help us document both
expectations and
validations now talking about
documenting expectations
um yoast will take you to this workshop
or to this
workflow and you know you will see
that you will get a very neatly
organized
html kind of file that kind of gives
some basic information about
uh your current configuration
but also about the
stuff that you're actually expecting so
about your expectations
for the data and if you follow
along this this document
will be under version control which will
also help you to know share
this information with stakeholders or
whoever you
find necessary also your fellow
developers
but that's not also also we can you know
we can document expectations but we can
also document
validations also in such a very very
neat
way of course this validations will not
be under version control
at least not by default because yeah
those might contain a little bit
sensitive information so you might not
want to share this with everyone but
yeah you will also get
a nicely organized html document that
kind of you know
lists both the expectations but also the
results
of those expectations and if something
goes wrong it will also elaborate
on this so
um all in all uh before we move on to
the
practical part uh i hope
we have managed to uh to assure you that
there are some benefits if you decide to
use
data validation tools such as great
expectation in your workflow
some of those benefits is yeah are very
obvious
so uh you want to
it will help the the workflow will help
you to ensure that
the data you you think that you are
using actually is the data that you're
using
it will also help you you know to
monitor uh the the data quality in
production
but also because uh
because it kind of produces
documentation it should also help you
with uh easing out handovers so
when you you know give a bunch of
expectations to somebody who first time
sees the data it will be very helpful
for them to understand kind of what this
data
is and uh how they should approach
the the yeah whatever the task they need
to do they will understand
the data a little bit better also
yeah you can use this workflow to
simplify the bugging
data pipelines when they start breaking
like i've shown you in my example
but also what you do if you apply this
you increase the visibility of
assumptions um
that you use when modeling so which is
really useful to share
this is really useful information to
share with you know other colleagues and
also
potentially somebody who's maybe not
working directly with you maybe analyst
or if you're giving a project to a data
engineer or something
and the nice added benefit of using
great expectations
for performing uh data quality checks
is that it kind of automates the
workflow
and general helps you generate the
documents automatically
with this um i'm gonna give
the the one to uh to mother long and
we're gonna go uh
to to to the hands-on part so
if you haven't please do uh clone our uh
repo and uh yeah follow the instructions
in uh read me and
code along with uh motherland
great thanks tommy i will share this
link also through the chat great
so please
please clone the repository from there
and then we can continue with the
hands-on
part of the workshop the first part
i will share my screen
can you see my screen now yeah
okay
so we'll wait for two minutes so that
you can clone the repository
so you can read the readme the
instructions are in there
and in the end we you should end up with
the notebook that you're currently
seeing
and then we can continue in a few
minutes
don't worry if you don't manage to set
up now
you can always go back to the repository
afterwards to
reproduce the notebook
but please if you run into issues you
can also ask them through the q a
and yoast and tommy will help you out
further
[Music]
all right is everyone ready please if
you're not
direct yourself to the q a and domingos
will help you further
so we will continue from here
so in this part we will cover a very
basic validation workflow
where you can use the api of great
expectations
so we will implement a very simple data
validation pipeline
we will see which expectations are built
into great expectations itself
but we will also see how we can
implement some custom functionality
and really tailor great expectations
towards the your domain needs
so to say
so let's start i hope you can all
see this notebook clearly so you can
work along so we first start with
doing some imports and here you see that
we are using some
fundus related modules from great
expectations
and that is because we will use the
pandas functionality from great
expectations
but you can also use for example spark
or
sql but for now we will
use pandas um
and before we continue with the great
expectations functionality
let's first have a look at the data that
we will be using
so today we will be looking at weather
data from brazil
from 2013 and we think this is an
interesting data set to have a look at
because as we said already we're from
heineken
and can we sell beers that sometimes
are well more popular in for example the
summer
or the winter so in general general
uh winter or weather data is interesting
to us
to analyze so let's have a look
at this file so what you see here
are some columns and each row contains a
measurement
a weather measurement from a certain
location which is
identified with the id and each
location like measurement location has a
latitude
a longitude it's somewhere in the city
and then each measurement is from a
specific
hour during a day so we are looking at
this data file that is in the repository
whether brazil 2013
01 which means we're looking at a data
file that contains all measurements from
all hours in a given month
and here you see at the right of this
data frame
you see all the uh yeah weather
properties that we are measuring so it
has the humidity the wind speeds but
also the temperature for example
so let's have a look at
what we will be implementing so
this figure will probably look familiar
to you because tommy already shared it
and what we will do today in this first
part of the hands-on session
is that we will be looking at a badge
and given that badge we will define some
expectations
for that specific patch and
from that from those expectations we
will validate our batch
against those and in the end we will
have a look at the validation result
we will do this a bit iteratively
starting with one simple expectation
and then building out further so let's
uh start
so as i said we will be using the
pando's functionality from
great expectations which means that i
can simply call
ge i've imported great expectations as
ge
dot read csv with the file path
we can do this because great
expectations
basically has a pandas dataset class
which extends the data frame class from
pandas so
we then have our batch and our batch is
basically
this data frame with some built-in
functionality from great expectations
so here you can see the type of this
object
which is basically the pandas data set
from great expectations
but if we just call head on that
we see that it's actually the data frame
again that we just saw when we read this
in with bondos
so this will be our batch
which is the same file that we just read
in i hope you all
follow along with me
and for example if we have such a
a badge coming in we would like to see
the columns in a very specific order
that could be one of the expectations
that we would have
from this data set so let's start with
with defining an expectation which
really expects all these columns
in this specific column order
so we will first define a list here
with all the with all the string columns
column names in it
and then you can already see
that it is simply a matter of calling
a method on this batch named expect
table columns to match ordered lists
and then you give in the required
columns that we just defined
to that expectation and that is really
as simple as it
is so we can call this
on our batch and by doing that
we have attached the expectation
of these having these columns in this
specific order
to this batch
and by doing so we can now simply
validate this batch
and then we see the json object
which is our validation result as tommy
has already discussed with you
and here we can see some statistics
of this specific validation run so here
we see that we have evaluated one
expectation
and that that given expect
expectation validation was successful so
our success percent is 100
and we see here a key of success
which denotes the overall success of the
entire validation
so imagine you have more expectations
[Music]
at this batch then this would give back
false if any of those expectations would
return yeah unmet
by that batch so
here we have some metadata as well
that denotes the the run runtime etc
that's validation
and we also see some very detailed
information about the expectation that
we
just did so here we see our expectation
that we set so expect table columns to
match ordered lists
and we gave this list as the expected
expected values and here on top of it
you see the observed values so
if it slightly differs from the expected
results
then you would see that for example the
column id
and elevation are swept
for example
and that's yeah so here is an
identifier if this expectation was
successful or not
so this will be false if this specific
expectation
would not be met by this batch
all right so now if we for example would
integrate this into a package or
data validation pipeline then we could
fire off the rest of the pipeline to
continue
if all the expectations are met by just
getting the success key from this
validation result
if it's true we could proceed with the
pipeline but if for example it's false
you could decide to break the pipeline
and
really give that feedback to the end
user so that's basically a very basic
workflow with
with great expectations and of course we
can
set some very specific and more domain
tailored expectations as well so for
example on the
column temperature so temp we could
say all right maybe we expect the
temperature to be
within minus 30 and 60 degrees
celsius um we of course looked it up
for brazil and it's more or less i think
it's the minimal temperature being
measured is -14
and the maximum around 45
degrees celsius so in the future we
would expect that it's
somewhere within these bounds
so we can simply attach this expectation
then
so expect column values to be between
minus 30 and 60 and
by doing that we have set that
expectation to our batch as well
but we could also for example
specify the longitude values that we
would expect for
all measurement locations within brazil
so then we would expect column values to
be between
minus 74 and minus 34
and we attach that expectation to the
column
long which refers to the longitude
of that location so we have now added
two expectations regarding specific
columns
on top of the general expectation
regarding all the column the column
order of this batch
so let's now validate that batch again
and see if
everything went well
no it did not so apparently there is one
expectation that is not met
but by this patch so let's have a look
which one it is so here again we have
this json
we see that only 66 more or less percent
has been met so indeed there's one
expectation
that wasn't successful so if we now look
at this
um jason we see this is success is true
of that expectation
expect column values to be between -30
and 60 of the temperature
this is also true so then it can only be
the last one
regarding the longitude values and
indeed
here you see that we have some
[Music]
unexpected values here namely zeros
and that was indeed beyond the limits of
brazil
so there are some um
[Music]
yeah column values that didn't
meet that expectation which is a great
find i think
because it would take some time to to go
over that in such a
large data file so indeed here you see
that this expectation
was false and therefore the overall
expectation was also false
all right so i think that
really illustrates the uh very simple
workflow for going from adding
expectations to a batch
validating the batch against those
expectations
and then inspecting the
the end result so now it would be great
if you
try this out yourself so please
access the dog strings through the
tooltips in jupiter notebook
or check out the glossary where you can
see
a full list of all the expectations that
are built into
great expectations we will share this
through the chat as well
so you can have a look and
of course you are free to implement any
expectation that you want
please share one of them through the
chat
and if you want some inspiration
maybe you can check if the column id
really has the data type ins
and i think they updated the package a
little bit
so you should be more specific with
being
in 64. so see if
from this glossary you can find
an implementation of an expectation that
expects the data type of the column id
to be of type in 64.
share that expectation to the chat and
then we will continue
in three minutes
oh i think we lost one or not
no i'm not sharing my screen now because
i'm
going to send the link to the glossary
of expectations
and i couldn't access the chats while
sharing uh
my screen the thing is floating at the
bottom somewhere
ah okay so also i've been coding along
nice
any expectation that you already found
this interesting
now i was actually looking uh
for the example like uh was this
question
about the um the data type on column
id from dennis no from yeah
that is asked like can you match columns
so it's looking if you can look for
for example sets values to be in the
column of the other one right
you say okay only the values have to be
the same as the values in the other one
multiple column values to be unique
that's a great question from sdg
if we can ignore or fix the broken
expectation
of course we could fix the data file
that is
underneath this batch but yoast will
show you in part two how you can be a
bit more flexible towards certain
expectations
so please stay tuned for for that part
as well
i was like the one with the increasing
expect column lives to be increasing as
you look as posting it
so you could maybe set that on the
dates exactly
please share through the chat and we'll
see what if it works out
i know already
[Music]
great
i'll give everyone a minute
so i see that aiden
has managed to implement the expectation
that we
be setting on the
[Music]
column values to be of type integer
so if you actually run this
you will see that integer is not
specific enough
if you change it to in 64
fortunately it's still true
so indeed that's how you could set
this expectation on the column id
let's see what we have for other
[Music]
so from carson we have an expectation
on the
on the timestamp
let's see okay yeah that's the that's
the perfect uh
description then of these time stamps
we have another one on the air pressure
i think that's
between 900 and 1050
oh that's interesting so we here have
some
unexpected values as well being zero
which probably doesn't correspond to
correct
air pressure so okay now we have
added these three expectations
i will stop my implementation here
but that's great so now we can validate
this patch again
with these expectations attached to it
and here then you see the results so we
have now evaluated in total six
expectations of which four were
successful
and the overall success is false because
indeed we had
like the
[Music]
the column values of zeros of the
longitude
location coordinates and
here we can see now that we've added
your expectations that you shared with
us through the jets
on the dates for daytime formats and
also on the air pressure so i think the
authors of this kaggle data set should
be fixing this data a little bit
if indeed these are unexpected
so now we have seen some built-in
expectations
from great expectations but we can also
implement some expectations ourselves
and we can do so by extending
the pandas dataset class from great
expectations
that allows us to make use of all the
built-in expectations
from great expectations itself but also
use our customer expectations so we do
that by defining this
new class here so oh
this is our batch still
so we have our class which we call the
custom bundles data set
and then we need to set the data asset
type
for great expectations so that great
expectation
can interpret this as being
a class with added custom expectations
to it
and by using this decorator
we can define some multi-column
expectations
and from this data
set so from our batch we could for
example
implement an expectation that checks if
every
id has exactly
one combination of latitude and
longitude values
because it will remain on the same
location
that's what we assume now and we want
that there are no different values for
these coordinates
for that specific location
so we will not fully go over this
implementation
but it's important that we check the
column combinations
to be unique where we check it
on the first column column id
and for doing this you have some
expectation format that you need to
compare to
so for example we should have a
bundle series with a boolean
indicating for each row if it is
successful or not
so if that expectation is met or not so
it should hold a false or true for every
row
and here we implemented some some
functionality to check
if for each id
value which we group on here
the combination of values
in the other columns that we
give in with the column lists are unique
so you can go over this expectation
in your free time later on but for now
let's see what it does so to make use of
our custom expectation
we need to read in this data file again
so we need to and that is because we
need to define that
we need the custom pandas dataset class
rather than the the usual
pandas dataset class built into great
expectations
so we can now read our batch in
with the custom
custom bundles data set here and then
we see that indeed our type now is the
custom bonus data sets so
we because we have now overwritten our
batch
we want to attach those expectations
that we already set
first so we have the required columns we
had an expectation on the temperature
and the longitudes
and then we had of course your
expectations and you can add them as
well
and now we want to make use of our
custom expectation
and we can do that simply by calling our
expectation
which was expect columns combination to
be
unique and we if
with that our list so the first
entry entry in our list will be um the
column that will be grouped by on and
then
we want the latitude and longitude uh
to be unique for every id that we
find in our data sets so let's
have a look and
now we have added this to our
expectation
to our batch i mean and we can
have a look at the results
so we now have 75 of success
and somewhere in this json
yeah here you go we now have as well our
custom expectation and we see that
we were successful so fortunately all
id location ids
have a unique pair of latitude and
longitude values
which is great and
that basically concludes our simple
workflow
so what we have seen in this part is
we have set some custom some built-in
expectations to
a batch we have created some custom
expectation and we added to that to that
same batch again
and we have seen how you can validate a
batch against
a few expectations and we have inspected
the validation outcome but now if we
would
like to um to validate
a new batch against the same
expectations
we would have to add those expectations
again for that batch and yoast
in part two will show you how to do that
more conveniently
and he will also show you how you can
generate
those better interpretable reports
and so in in terms of documentation but
also how we can
visualize those validation outcomes
better so please stay tuned
for yos we'll now continue with part two
of this workshop
yes thanks mylon um so let me share my
screen
yeah so um now that we've used uh
more api sort of functionality from um
which madeleine explained
this part is more about how to go from
like a quick overview to an actual
production-like environment
so within any data pipeline how would we
actually implement this
um and i'm gonna
show you um so we're gonna create this
great expectations project which they
call a data context
i'll go back to that later i'll show you
some profiling functionality that's
been built in in the great expectations
framework then we're going to create
some
expectations edit them and
show the validation results
so i hope this is big enough but this is
the
same diagram that marlon and tommy
also showed but a little bit i'm going
to expand a little bit on this
so the whole thing here that's what they
call a data context so that will hold
all your configuration files
um all your expectations in the json
files that you make and it's just a
really great way of putting them into
your source control and sharing between
your team
what is going on everybody knows what
the expectations are of the data
and it's really easy to not only
validate but also see
what other people expect from the data
so let me start and show you how to set
up
and create expectations project you
don't have to follow along
at the end if you have cloned the repo
you'll be at the same point
where i will end so uh i mean feel free
to follow along but you don't
have to because yeah
let's run for a moment can you zoom in a
little more so people can read it
yes
is this better i think so for me it's at
least a little better
okay maybe also put the let's set fuse
code in full screen at the top left
yeah yeah thanks okay
so let's set up our first project so i'm
going to
do great expectations which just the
command line interface that they've
provided
so i'm just going to do the init
function
what this will do it will create a very
basic
structure of all the great expectations
features that are in there so it's just
a folder structure
which will um yeah again you put this
into your source control
and then everybody that adds something
will see the same exactly the same
files that you're looking at
so it's asking me to create a new
directory so
this has some configuration files
the expectations which are json format
checkpoints
we'll go over that later and there's an
uncommitted folder
so that doesn't live in your source
control that's per user
which then hold results
based on your own validations you'll see
that
in a bit as well so okay to proceed i'm
going to do yes here
would you like to configure a data
source now to show where the data source
is i'm going back to the slides um so
that's
this part on the left so we've already
talked about batches
these batches are converted into what
they has great expectations called data
asset and you run the expectations on
this data asset
the details don't really matter for now
but just that we have the naming i think
you guys know what we're talking about
that's the name that they use a data
asset
so do we want to configure a data source
and it's
yes we are interested in files but you
could also
connect it to your sql instance or um
or to spark for example we're going to
go with pandas
so i'm going to choose one for files
then i'm going to choose one for
us so the path here is
the data folder that we have so that's
just
data as we're talking about weather
data i'm gonna name this
for weather data and here you see a
little example of what
your yaml file would look like so your
configuration of your data sources
this could have have multiple data
sources
and they all look like this i'm not
going to go into all the details now but
it's just really good to know that this
lives in your source control
and that great expectations knows where
to find
the data would you like to profile the
expectations
um i'm going to do no for now because
i'm going to show that in a second
and so that's it and so now we've
created this folder
um yeah exactly as what was mentioned
here you can see all these different
file folders and
we're going to populate them a little
bit now
so to understand what i'm going to do
next is i'm going to run profiling on
our data
yes excuse me can you please just zoom
in a little bit
uh in the chat there are comments that
people do not see the scheme very well
so
let me see if i can put this up
yep better i'm gonna assume yes because
it doesn't get bigger for me
um so we're gonna run the profiling uh
part here and that's just a really neat
feature that
great expectations has built in and it's
just
a nice way of showing looking at
the data so it's not deep diving it's
just
exploratory analysis but as you will see
in a second
it has some quite neat features
so i'm going to go back to my terminal
here i'm going to clear the output
so great expectations i'm just going to
run it without any command so we see
what
what all the options are
and yeah as you saw in the diagram where
we want to profile a data source
so let's have a look at what
data source what are the options there
um so you can delete them you can list
all one you can make a new one
i want a profile one so
let's see what that looks like and if
it's all
going a bit fast um we're going to go
back and forth over this a couple of
times so don't worry if it's
too much for now but also please feel
free to tell me if i'm going too fast
so let's do profile
then let's ask you mean which
data do we want to profile i'm gonna go
for specify a list of the data assets
and because we already gave in what the
data folder is it
knows that these files are in there and
i'm gonna go with
just this first one i don't want to do
all of them
i just want to show what it looks like
okay and so now you can see that it's
been
analyzing all these columns
and going back to the diagram you
present this
what you see here is a feature which is
called the data docs
and data docs are nothing else than an
interface to all your
json and configuration files so it's
it's an
it's an index.html file so just some
uh web page that shows you
um all the uh yeah configuration and
json files in your project
so what it's asking me now is do i want
to create this data docs
so i'm going to say yes here
[Music]
now it's building a data docs and
automatically pops up here
so this is the interface that you would
get
if you would run it in a more
productionized environment so you can
see what all your runs have done
what the expectations are so let's go
into this profiling
so here you can see these are my
profiling results
i'm going to go in here so first column
id
it expects it to be so we haven't told
it anything about the data yet this is
all just assumptions that it's making
so there's 112 distinct values in this
these are some of the example values and
it's of type int
for elevation it expects it to be float
etc etc cities here which is just a
really neat way to
get like some really high overview
really quickly on your data
and for some of the values if it thinks
that it makes sense
it'll do some more than just
type checking but it will also give you
a mean minimum maximum
plot out some histograms again these are
not tailored specifically to your data
so sometimes they work a little bit
better than others
but it's just a really good way of like
going from a
from nothing to some sort of idea about
your data
so i'm going to go back home here so
that was the profiling
part
and the next step would then be so all
these expectations that marlon and tommy
also showed
within a production environment these
will be bundled together
in what's called an expectation suite so
that's just your
it's just a store of all your
expectations so just a way of
yeah like collecting just to collecting
all the expectations
and you can edit or add
these expectations to jupyter notebooks
which i'll come back into a second but
let's first create an expectation suite
so again great expectations let's see
what all the options are
um i want to go with sweetly because we
want to create a new one
so
sweet and then again you can
delete edit list them we're going to go
with new and
i'm going to show you what the options
are there
so i'm going to create a new one but i'm
going to give it two flags so the one is
a suit so the suit name i'm going to
call this demo suite
demo now and i want this to be empty
because i just want to start from
scratch to show
everybody what it's look like if you
don't have anything in it
because otherwise it's going to populate
it based on the profiling so there'll be
some basic expectations there
but for this we don't want that
so i'm going to run that what
data assets do i want to run this on
so again the first file we've been using
and it's opening up two things now
so one is the edit your expectation
suite
the other is again the data docs
so the expectation suite that's what you
saw
in the
that's this bit where it's this is your
interface of
editing your expectation suite so they
provide you with a jupiter notebook
that allows you to edit your expectation
sheet in a really easy manner
so let's have a look at that the first
part is just some boilerplate code that
they made
what is important here is that it's
loading the context
so again that was this whole project
then it's um giving it an expectation
suite name
which we just created which was all the
expectations
and uh the batch keyword arguments
that's in here that's
just so it on this badge it's just to
know
what files am i supposed to look at
where can i find these and some extra
keyword arguments that you want to put
in
and so we're going to get this badge
and you'll see here the first five rows
of the data
madeleine also showed you this i'm
hoping this is not a surprise
and i'm gonna add exactly the same
expectations that madelung was
using in part one so i have these here
i'm just gonna copy them and paste them
back in
so there's basically no new expectations
here this is exactly what we've been
doing in part one
so let me add those you can already see
the success is false
and i think modeling also showed you
this but these are all the zero values
that it's not expecting
and then i'm going to save and review
the expectations
what it's then going to do is it's going
to run this expectation
suite as well so in here it's
automatically going to validate this
and it's going to come up with an
expectation validation result
so let's do that
so here we go yeah so this walkthrough
uh great for the first time but
i'm not gonna go over that feel free to
in your own time i'm gonna be
clicking it away constantly okay so
here you see um an expectation result
it's the it's exactly an interface to
the json file that's in your project
structure
so here you see that we
defined these column names and in order
that worked out fine
but for some reason there are zero got
zeros in here
for 744 of the rows so for
0.9 percent we have unexpected values
and this one yeah this one passed
so i just want to show you quickly where
to find this json file that you're
actually looking at now
so in here you have your demo suite.json
and this is the file that you put in
your source control
that everybody can have a look at but
obviously this doesn't
it's not really readable so that's why
you have the data docs but it's good to
know
that it lives here in your source
control
okay so now we want to fix this right
because
um yeah we're either
our validation reports are failing so we
can either change the data itself
or we can change the expectation
yeah and with normal software
engineering i think tests should be
really
rigid and that's really good but with
data as it's so
it's flowing and stuff can break they've
built in a great feature
and that is to say that we want this to
be true most of the time
but it's also okay if it's not
always correct so i'm going to say this
needs to be correct mostly
95 percent of the time yes can you zoom
in a bit
on the notebooks again
yeah okay thanks
okay so um i want this
column to be within values between minus
74
and -34 95 of the time
so let's run this again then i'm going
to save
my expectation suite again
[Music]
and then it's going to automatically run
this
[Music]
walkthrough again and here now we can
see that it passed
even though that we have an unexpected
value of count of 744
with 0.9 unexpected um
we just say it's okay if it's not always
100 correct
um yeah and so even going back to the
document
uh like the the index of the the dogs
we have your validation results
which are also stored together
and this is more for so we understand
what's exactly going on we had one
validation
result before and this is just a store
of all your validation
results and again this is
an interface in your data docs to your
expectation results so here you see
these
validation results and now
let's see how we can actually put this
into oh yeah so this is good so we have
our profiling results here
in the expectation suite here that i
created demo suite
which just holds these three
expectations
but now let's see how we can put this
into a more productionized
or how this would fit in into your data
pipeline
there's definitely multiple ways to
implement this
but i'm going to show this to the
jupiter
notebook that we've created
so in my terminal here um i'm going to
open up a new one
and i'm just going to do jupiter
notebook
i'm going to go into part 2.
so in part two this is it's only five
cells but we want to make sure that we
run this
expectation suite that we created over
all of the batches of our data
so this is just an import this is a
function to validate the badge
[Music]
here i'm loading in the context so again
your whole
great expectations project
i'm gonna um yeah just kind of look over
all the data the data folder and all the
csv files
i'm defining my suite name that i
created so this was demo suite
and then for all of these batches we're
going to run these validations
so let's see if that works
ah so there's already one failing on
this part so there's a couple of them
that are failing
which is intended because tommy uh slav
um yeah he uh
messed up the data on purpose so that's
good and uh he'll tell you later a
little bit about
what we expect you to do on that
but so it's good to know that i have
this jupyter notebook open
for my for the part two and this would
just really be
like in a data pipeline this is then
easily how you import your demo suite
your context and you just run this over
your
batches so if i go back to my data docs
and i refresh this page
now here you can see all my
um runs that i just did and you see that
a couple of them are failing
and there's a couple of more here and so
this is just a really neat way of
getting all your batches of data running
the same suite which lives in source
control that you can share between the
team
and everybody knows exactly what they
should expect because we can look at the
expectation suite here
so this is what we expect from the data
if you want to add something
file uh pull request other people can
look at it and
over time this will build up to be like
a really nice expectation suite on your
data
and then i'm going to hand it over to
tommy again who's going to show you a
little bit
on the exercise
tommy think you're muted still
[Music]
yeah can everybody hear me now yes
excellent so uh thanks a lot jos uh
so uh now it's a time for a challenge so
we did prepare a little bit of uh
practice uh a little bit of a challenge
you know so that you can also uh
practice and
uh put this uh
put the skills that you just obtained to
you good use
so what we have uh we prepared
some batches of the data this weather
data that you're already to some extent
uh familiar with
but we also uh introduced some mistakes
in this data
um so just as a as a quick start uh
suggestion we have i think
uh 12 more minutes to run through so
yeah you have to um you know feel free
to continue at your own time later on
but uh yeah the suggested workflow will
be out
to enter your terminal and uh run this
command
here to uh start the start editing
the the suite that you already created
so this demo suite
and uh yeah you will enter the notebook
and you know
start using this batch expect syntax
that model on the neos went
over through with you and uh
use the workshop pi data part two
notebook
you know to validate the expectations
that you have made and saved in uh
step step two and uh please do let us
know what you uh what you found we're
very
interested i think some of those
expectations already
are were found during the demo but
there are more so um here are some
hints for what what happened so you
could for instance check if the
temperature units are
remaining consistent throughout all the
batches you could also check whether
there are
some batches there where the columns are
missing
uh maybe there's also a column in order
i think
this might already ring a bell for some
of you who are following it along
also maybe check whether there's
something happening with time stamps in
some of the batches that's quite
always suspicious when you have date
times
and check whether columns that should be
percentages
actually do not go over or under
this is also and yeah who knows
you might have already found some of
those for those who followed along
and if there are any more mistakes here
please also do let us know
um i will give some time now
to the maybe five five minutes or so and
then
i'm gonna for the curious go over to the
potential solutions that we suggest yes
we'll just uh as i wanted to mention we
got the
question in the chat or whether we'll be
posting solutions to the challenge yes
we will be posting
potential solutions uh to this challenge
uh
there as you know many ways to skin a
cat so these are just our suggestions to
uh to tackle this particular uh
challenges
so um yeah please um do get
on with it for those who want to follow
so here is um the information that uh
you might uh that might be worth looking
at for you and
in the meantime we can use this time to
maybe answer some of the questions
uh that you might have
yes so are we asking questions so people
can uh
either continue listening or start with
the uh
the exercise um
so i was wondering um given that it's
still a little bit unstable but do you
have this running in production
somewhere
so there are use cases where we use this
uh you have to be yeah you have to be a
little bit mindful about which version
you're using
because uh the api can uh change but
uh yeah as far as do correct me host and
model
as far as we know this is uh yeah the
tool that that's really the most
convenient
for the reason that it not only
helps you find mistakes in your data but
also for the fact that you can use
you know use your business knowledge
about the data
your expectations no pun intended about
the data
to also create documentation so in a
sense you know
what authors of the package like to say
is
that tests are docs and docs are tests
so yeah it's uh
it's not uh perfect it's a but uh it's
uh
it's quite flexible there are multiple
ways that you can use it and it uh
enables you to yeah it does the job you
just have to be a little bit uh mindful
the api will change for sure
do you have it running at uh heineken
somewhere else
i think yours can answer this yeah so
what we've been
uh the first phase was the bit that
madeleine explained
so that's that's what we currently have
been doing and
experimenting with but the next step
would be
to actually implement this into
production uh like what i showed in part
two
but um that's currently work in
production or work in progress but
it already helped a lot with the the
part that madelon showed
because there's so much code
custom code being written by the data
scientist to check
column values to check column types and
everybody has
their own solution so there's no really
there was no great way of
sharing these expectations between teams
or even between data scientists
so um currently we're in part one and
then
hopefully uh soon we're implementing the
part two a bit more
cool thank you also for the attendees
feel free to ask questions
um so now almost like five to four ten
thirty so five minutes the official part
will end
but i think tommy yost and alumni will
stay for a little bit longer
also to answer your question you still
have questions
about the assignment as well and we have
some aftercare
in the uh the discord so we do encourage
you to
try it yourself do the simon tommy
explains
and then via the discorded channel uh
you can
find we can ask questions and we can
discuss further and
we also will share some content
um so are there any other questions
and ask them via the q a i think yes sir
just ask the question but i see it
disappeared already
but he was asking if it could be doable
to for example validate a
data set which had well say
300 columns so then you wouldn't
need to you don't want to like define a
list with 300
column names in it manually i think this
is a
great way for the profiler
to to really see what's in your data
and probably the profiler if you have a
data file that is
really as you expect it to be then you
can use it to profile your data
and that will then automatically
generate this expectation suite for you
and also the expectations
given the columns basically
i think that's a great use case for the
profiler but you can also
uh infer those column names that you
wanted to have
in a different manner and give that as a
yeah required column lists basically
you also have something like a connector
to uh
to like an sql schema that you convert
schemas from whatever origin
to these expectations
yeah yeah there's a lot of functionality
in there to also provide for
uh sequel instance definitely have a
look at the documentation later
um again it's still working progress
also from
from from their side so they're really
working hard on uh
on creating all the right documentation
but there's um
yeah there's a slack channel where
people are uh
pretty active on and um there there's
definitely good
sql uh functionality there
[Music]
okay maybe looking at the time shall we
uh go
slowly through the solutions
let's get one let's do that
so again these are potential solutions
now so you might have
been correct and implemented something
different
um so the the one of the files 2013
february um we replaced the timestamp
format
here and yeah you can find this
uh this issue by uh yeah having this
expectation so you have expect column
volumes to match some kind of string
format time where you specify the time
step
which column you want to check and the
desired format
so this is how we can catch this mistake
then we had one column where we
converted
degrees celsius into into fahrenheit
[Music]
um yeah this is actually um now i see
the the
title is wrong so the original
temperature is in celsius we converted
it to fahrenheit
so uh one way to do it is just to expect
column values to be between
certain limits so in this case minus 20
and
60 you can optionally specify like a
kind of like fault tolerance if you want
as uh just mentioned
um in 2013 uh september file we removed
solar radiation columns so i think
this is quite the easy one to uh to
catch
there are again multiple solutions that
you can you know
that you can use to do to catch this
we also uh played a little bit with a
column order so uh in
2014 may we moved the id
column uh to the end and
uh yeah this it also probably
um caught this one
and in uh in uh june 2014
we've offset relative humidity by
by 10 which causes it to go um over
over 100 percent in the data so that's
also one of the sanity checks that
you can use uh to you can use this
uh this method expect column values to
be between again two
to catch this zero maybe you came up
with something original and if you did
please do share it
we're super curious also if there are
other
mistakes that we in the data also super
curious to find out
and uh yeah at the end i think we're
almost on time
uh so um if you will have further
questions
in in future yeah just don't hesitate
to to drop us an email and
we'll be also present here to answer
your questions during the
during the after queer during the africa
this morning and
in the evening i think that's
everything that we have prepared for
today i hope that you
like the workshop i hope that you you
found it useful and i hope
that you are now motivated not only to
check your code but
also to check your your data
that's your code is working with and
i hope you will have less issues in the
in the future with uh with your five
points
yes thank you very much tony yosemite so
thank you for the great expectation
workshop
um for those who still have questions
you can still answer we'll
stay around here for a moment i already
saw it
uh one before so it's kind of similar
but
if you do if you talk about data drift
is it possible for
within great expectations to define
something
saying hey we use this data set it
should be kind of similar to
a new an update for example so that you
measure if your data is drifting in some
way
is that also possible to do yeah but i
think
that you should do that more so they
have this concept of checkpoints
so you can say uh like at some
checkpoint you want to end this
uh like you want to run batches uh and
so
for a new checkpoint you would then
refer back to
the you'd store some data
based on your last run and you have to
collect that data again and use it as a
new
validation it kind of depends on what
kind of
data pipeline you're using so for
example they have great
uh integrations with airflow
but also different kinds of schedulers
so
it's not as straightforward yet as
you would hope i guess but there's
definitely uh options to do that
cool that's nice
you say airflow and i imagine
so let's also talk about sql if you have
a lot of data
is this possible to do in uh something
like spark if you simply don't want to
do that
what do you mean in if you want to do it
a lot of data and
would you recommend doing this in
something distributed like spark where
you say take a sample and
apply your expectations to the sample
that will be a good approach there
yeah that's that's really that's
difficult to answer so far
you do some statistical expectations
which which i think is great on to do on
on a sample um like the data is not
going to change too much if the
if you put it on the whole data set
or you can take like a good sample but
the other thing is where you really want
to make sure that
all the data is correct then you need to
scale up with something like spark or
whatever so it depends a little bit on
the use case
we didn't go over that too much but
there's a lot of like
statistical expectations as well which
are really nice so you could check like
uh
yeah like what uh what the distributions
are for certain
values and then i think a sample would
be sufficient
but if you want to be really rigid and
make sure that all of your
data is correct then you uh yeah you
need to check
all the data you need to scale up in
some way so either a
like a spark whatever feature use case
it's supposed to be really flexible uh
between different technologies
yeah but also talking about like uh why
would you
check like if you receive the data in
batches
there's uh yeah i don't see that many
use cases where you want to
like uh check everything all the time
right
well i think you need like videos
answered quite well depends on the use
case
yeah and i've got a question here for
mario
would you think great expectation be a
good substitute for checking for missing
values or outliers
well i think answer this one
um yeah so great expectations has some
custom
like oh sorry not custom but build in
expectations
that check if for example column values
should are no and i think it's called
expect column values to not be null
so then it it checks if um yeah if you
have any missing values
and then on the outlier part i think
they have
so you can check for certain
distributions
um and but yeah outliers are
of course always a bit complicated to
check because it really depends on how
you define an outlier so therefore you
can
also check if yeah
you can be really narrow on the range
that you expect your column values to be
within
for example okay
can you use yeah another question from
jessica
can you use great expectation to define
actions for example
if an entry does not adhere to criterium
drop it from your dataset
and store it in a different file
that's a really good question i don't
think the great expectations itself
is will help you in that but you can use
it as a tool
so based on your on your results
you know which rows are unexpected
and then you could write some other
functionalities in your pipeline so
maybe if it's air airflow
you'd write some sort of airflow
operator that will
grab these files and store them
somewhere else
but in the core package of great
expectations that is not built in
as far as i know could be a cool feature
it's uh all
open source uh feel free to contribute
[Music]
so um that actually brings to the
question like uh
it also depends a little bit of course
on what is expected down the pipeline
right so
if somebody's expecting the column to be
there it might break also the whole
thing
yeah it would also be like nice to have
this refuel
sort of like you say okay this is going
to be accepted and the other one's going
to be review or
yeah yeah so in terms of maybe that's
what the actions was about you can
definitely hold
like you can post you can
for example post to slack if something's
breaking or you can stop your pipeline
by giving out a signal
so that's definitely sure but again it
all depends a little bit on your
your technology stack
yeah i think they have they implement
validation operators i believe you
didn't mention them yet but you can
implement whether you send out
notifications through slack for example
based on the validation results and then
you can also
implement custom validation operators so
for example it would be very nice to see
if indeed you can
implement such actions
through that
[Music]
okay yeah more questions i'm gonna take
this moment to
yet again share with you the
slides for today so talking about open
source um
and contributing to open source uh at 12
30 today we have a spring preparation
this is for those who want to get
prepared for over contributing to open
source especially if you've never done
it before
and it's in preparation for our saturday
where you contribute to open source
pandas but maybe next year for example
if you can ask great expectations and
join us and
host a sprint for them and
we're looking forward to having you
during the lunch
and also definitely join tonight for a
keynote and the opening notes
and we have two more talks so i hope you
enjoyed the
workshop uh thank you again tommy yost
and alone from heineken
for joining us and explaining great
expectations
yeah thanks for having us girl one more
year one more question though
i'm curious if there's a link with the
novel
that's the one for tommy to
yeah uh i'm not familiar with it
but there might have been probably an
internal discussion which has
moved the expectations part of the
expectations
package by the others but
i cannot elaborate further on that we
have some theories but i think that's uh
for uh for later we're offline
all right okay so um you'll be in
discord for the next hour still on
night so anybody who's working on the
assignment
uh use the time to ask joe's mom and
tell me
questions if you're stuck and also
collaborate with each other and
communicate so
good luck cory you will be sharing the
slides right
yeah as well okay perfectly from the
committee
okay perfect thanks cool all right
thanks
you